are so many sports teams in La there's
also so many other things that people
love to do like going to the beach or
going to the movies but you also have
people who love sports I wasn't even
into sports very much but I was so
inspired by what these soccer players
were doing Portman says she was fueled
by her son's enthusiasm for Women's
World Cup soccer I think we can all see
ourselves and look up to Greatness when
we see it it's important to me that when
I see in the stadium all these
children's all genders looking up to our
female athletes it just feels like
culture change during the pandemic the
power players met over
are together they created better working
conditions for their athletes including
training for post-playing careers and
Angel City players receive a cut of the
money made from ticket sales a first of
its kind in women's sports
[Applause]